[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
hey everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
my name is karen miner i'm part of the
leadership team
and i am so glad you're with us tonight
happy spring
uh and i was just looking at our live
stream and it's so cool to see all the
names
uh some people i haven't seen in a while
others who
have been here gosh almost every week
as we've been online so thank you for
joining us your presence
matters um i just have a couple
of announcements to kick us off tonight
with
the first is a volunteer opportunity one
of the organization's
local organizations that we partner with
is five loaves they're a food pantry
in the saxi area and we are going to be
serving
with them stocking food
helping them with whatever they need and
we're going to be doing this
as a group this coming friday the 26th
at 5 00 pm
so it's a way to get involved in a local
organization
and help five lives which has been one
of the heroes of this pandemic in our
area
so marissa our wonderful host for
tonight
is going to put that link in our
comments and that will have
all of the details and a way for you to
sign up
this is open to anyone kids adults
whoever
if you would like to and are available
we would love to have you
join in and serve five loves this coming
friday night
secondly we have a slew of ways to get
connected at the table with our services
coming up for holy week
the first one is we have our good friday
service coming up on friday april 2nd
this is going to be an online service at
7pm
so it's it's not our usual 5 pm slot it
is
not our usual sunday slot it's friday
at 7 pm and i hope you'll join us for
that it's just a great way to
remember jesus and those
dark hours before he was crucified
before he was resurrected
um so we'll start with good friday
service and then we'll have our easter
sunday service two days later
that will be a morning service that
sunday 10 30 a.m
and we're gonna do an outdoor uh service
in person
um the location is coming soon we're
just waiting for a few more details and
we'll get that out to you as soon as we
know
um and then lastly
we're so excited to announce that we're
going to gather again
in person back at pleasant valley
methodist church in saxi
that will be happening on uh
april 11th which is the sunday after
easter and so
we're going to be following social
distancing guidelines
and making sure everything is clean and
safe for you
and so with that we will need to have
people sign up
so in order to do that you need to be on
our email list so if you are not already
on our email distribution list if you're
not getting any communication from the
table
you want to do that regardless we've got
great stuff that goes out every single
week
and i believe marissa's gonna put that
link up right now
please put yourself on that distribution
list stay up to date on everything going
on at the table
um now before we uh
head into the rest of our service i did
want to take a moment
to acknowledge the horrific shooting
that happened in atlanta
this past week and not just the
the the shooting but also the ongoing
violence against the asian american and
pacific islander community
this is going on for has been going on
for a while and it's actually rooted in
centuries
of of oppression and things that have
happened here in america
so often those of us not directly
and instantly affected by hate crimes
and domestic terrorism
are reactionary instead of visionary
we speak out and we do something after a
tragic event happens
once it becomes a hashtag the times in
between
we tend to be asleep and oblivious to
the cries of injustice
and warnings coming from the margins and
the warnings and the cries are always
there
this mirrors this mirrors jesus jesus
in the garden of gethsemane where he
asks his disciples his closest friends
to keep watch
while he goes and prays to god and
agonizing sorrow
knowing he will soon be brutally
tortured and murdered on a cross
jesus says to his friends my soul is
overwhelmed with sorrow to the point of
death
stay here and keep watch with me and
that's my question for us tonight
how will we keep watch how are we
keeping watch
not just immediately following a tragedy
like what happened in atlanta
but how are we bearing witness to our
siblings in christ and standing in
solidarity
and lamenting with them and grieving
and taking action as well
so please join me in this prayer of
lament and confession
and this is this uh prayer is from black
liturgies
so please pray with me god
whose friends fall asleep whose friends
fell asleep to your pain in the garden
we confess that many of us have fallen
asleep to the pain
to asian people in our midst be near to
every asian person
whose pain and trauma is so often
ignored
is so often dismissed help us
to bear witness to their tragedies and
make space for them
in our hearts and minds and cravings for
justice
may those who fear today be met with
divine protection
cover them in a peace that allows them
to still grieve
in the way we were meant to may those
who are angry be met with a holy rage
guide them to people who will not demand
their complacency
or their emotions to be subdued but who
remind them
they are worthy of fighting for of
crying for
it is not well and we will say so
together
remind us today their grief will not be
erased
in jesus name amen
thanks so much for joining me in that
prayer and for being with us tonight
we're going to transition into a time of
musical worship and then into the
message
so i'm gonna hand it off to mindy now
and then i'll be back with you again
to close out our service later
all right hey guys it's mindy um
yeah i hope you guys are having a good
weekend
our weekend has been uh full of all
things
spring at least what i think of us
spring so
we have had volleyball games and soccer
games
and baseball games and all the games
and gardening still our deconstruction
gardening has
now turned the corner into
reconstruction gardening and that has
been
a sweet and beautiful thing um and a lot
of work we're so sore
but it has also brought with it just the
reminder
of newness and what this season
um is kind of symbolic of in our lives
you know when the old passes away and
the new comes and you start to see all
the new buds on the trees and
um you're just getting that sense of
like something is coming
and um it reminds me of
second corinthians in that passage that
says
um whoever is in christ he
is a new creation the old has gone away
do you see it fresh things are coming
and i feel like that is my reminder
everywhere i look right now like do you
see it the old is going
fresh things are coming new is coming
and i love that about jesus i love that
about
um this season and um so
i wanted to start us off this week with
the song springtime it just seemed
so fitting as it is right around the
corner
so you guys join in with me and um
here we go
you're the resurrection
that we waited for
[Music]
you're the king of heaven
the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder
[Music]
[Applause]
we will sing
[Music]
[Applause]
is like springtime
[Music]
shining you restore my soul
the deeper you call us grow the deeper
we'll go
[Music]
we're coming back
time
[Music]
and like a garden
i will be
[Music]
is
we're reaching towards the light
we will sing this song
[Music]
reaching towards the light
more love is
[Music]
all right i'm gonna pass it to gary and
he is going to
lead us in some songs that remind us of
that identity that we have
in christ and that we are new we are his
and he has formed us so go ahead gary
[Music]
who am i that the highest king
would welcome me
i was lost but he brought me
[Music]
oh he's free
his grace runs deep
while i was a slave to sin jesus died
for me yes he died for
me
[Music]
i'm a child of god
yes i am
he's my father's house
there's a place for me
i'm a child of god
yes i am
[Music]
i am chosen not forsaken
i am you
are for me not against me
cause i have to say i am
i am chosen not forsaken
i am
[Music]
the sun sets free
oh he's free indeed
i'm a child of god
yes i am
[Music]
he was just in my
he shares a melody and tells me to
repeat it
[Music]
and it believes
he says i am
[Music]
and he says
he reminded me
[Music]
he says i am
i'm more
and he says i am
[Music]
scales
broken
[Music]
anymore
i'm no slave to sin
[Music]
i'm alive i'm alive
he says i am
[Music]
he says
well hello everyone good evening
grace and peace and welcome to the table
and a huge thank you to gary and mindy
for music and uh karen for opening
us and um it is it's just great great to
be with you all
um as karen mentioned i'm really uh
grateful
to to be back with you all in person
very very soon uh easter sorry for the
delay on that location
we've been working hard on it for a few
weeks but we're kind of in conversations
with the city we have like an
application
um with the city of garland right now
and they need to like approve it for a
spot and all this stuff so
um anyway so it's it's uh hopefully it
should be this this week that we
get word on that soon so um yeah so we
got easter and then of course uh the
11th
we'll be back at pleasant valley uh
united methodist church and sexy and
uh man that's going to be great to see
some faces
and all that so um all right
this is part five in our series
uh titled lent from repentance to
renewal
and uh the season of lent in the
christian calendar is
a season of roughly 40 days leading
right up to good friday and
then easter so it's it's kind of a time
of spiritual preparation
uh really for the broader you know
christian church as whole but also ours
and so i encourage you to stay strong in
whatever maybe spiritual discipline you
might have taken
up in the season or anything you might
have given up
uh we're getting close to our goal since
next week is palm sunday
and then that sends us right into holy
week so uh
stay on the path my friends so our
primary texts we have two tonight two
scriptures
um they're gonna be john chapter 12
verses 24 and 25
and then matthew 7 verses 24-27 so i'll
start with this
passage from john and this is jesus
speaking
and actually both of these is jesus
speaking so very truly
i tell you unless a kernel of wheat
falls to the ground
and dies it remains only a single seed
but if it dies it produces many
seeds anyone who loves their life will
lose it while anyone who hates their
life in this world will keep it for
eternal life and now matthew 7 starting
in verse 24
therefore everyone who hears these words
of mine jesus says and puts them into
practice
is like a wise man who built his house
on the rock
the rain came down the streams rose the
winds blew and they
beat against that house and yet it did
not fall
because it had its foundation on the
rock
but everyone who hears these words of
mine and does not put them into practice
is like a foolish man who built his
house on sand
the rain came down the streams rose the
winds blew
and beat against that house and it fell
with a great
crash so the title of my message
tonight is rebirth rebirth and here is
my big idea
and it um it comes in the form of a
question tonight
so here it is what do you need to die to
so that you can really live
what do you need to die to so that you
can really
live as jesus just said in the john 12
passage verse 24 very truly i tell you
unless a kernel of wheat
falls to the ground and dies
it remains only a single seed um
and this of course this is a word
picture it's a metaphor
uh not actually about well the point
isn't the wheat it's a metaphor for us
right he's talking about us you see an
essential part of the gospel message of
jesus
is the idea that the old you must die
so that the new you the true you the
christ like you
can be born this has been very much a
theme of the past few months
because this is where the crucifixion uh
and resurrection of jesus touches down
in our own lives
because the idea is that what happened
to jesus
in his crucifixion resurrection will
happen spiritually emotionally
psychologically
to you right the old you must die so
that the new you the christ like you can
be
born because uh here's here's what we do
we build our lives
we build our identity that's the key
word
we build our identity on what jesus in
matthew chapter 7
calls sand there's an old hymn
that you may recognize it goes
like this on christ the solid
rock i stand all other ground is
sinking sand all other ground is
sinking sand and
uh that may sound like pious
niceties uh you know just sort of like
oh an old
hymn that i used to hear or something
uh but what that's i mean that's
actually a really serious song
because what what it's really about is
it's talking about identity
right because what we do is we build our
life
we build our sense of self
too often not on the rock solid
foundation
and you say what would be the rock what
is well it'd be something like this this
this is the the rock solid foundation of
our identity is that i
am a child of god fully loved fully
known
and because of that truth now i am free
to love
free to know and relate to others even
my enemies
from that grounded god-centered place
right that's to build on the rock um
but so often we don't build from there
do we instead
we build our lives we build our sense of
self
on well i mean almost anything
but that uh let me give you give you
four things tonight that we build our
sense of self our identity on number one
i build my sense of value on
family on family uh
so it sounds something like this you
know i am part of of such and such
family and they love me and they accept
me
and so i have worth and value
because they say i do
and uh now just be clear i'm not you
know saying of course family's bad
uh family does play a strong part in our
just human development especially as
children
but sometimes we get older without
growing up knowledge
uh it's not the same thing as wisdom age
is not the same thing as maturity
and what can happen is is that instead
of
um kind of passing through that phase
um and then learning to relate to our
family in a more kind of adult way what
happens is we can get enmeshed
kind of emotionally fused with our
families
such that if if they are thinking
well of me well then i can think well of
me
but if they do not think well of me
uh-oh what happens
i start to crack as the hymn says
all of the grounded sinking sandals
other ground is sinking
sand all right so that's first i build
my sense of value on
on family uh second i build my sense of
value
on group identity so
family would be sort of a subset of this
point but here i'm naming kind of the
broader
thing right family's not the only group
we often derive
our sense of identity value sense of
worth
from uh you know i'm part of such and
such group
like i drive a harley so
i'm part of the edgy motorcycle group
clearly i don't drive a harley you get
what i'm saying
the analogy someone maybe someone
listening you drive a harley and you
know it's like
part of the club you know there's like a
whole identity and people
start like wearing different kind of
vests and things like yeah and they do
like this signal as they drive by
whatever
whatever it is and they have this you
know their ways right it's and you're
kind of getting
an identity going or of course this
happens in politics right i'm a lifelong
republican or i'm a democrat or i'm a
libertarian you're freedom
uh or i'm from the north so i'm northern
or i'm
southern or i'm a feminist or i'm an
anti-feminist or you know i'm part of
such and such culture or group or race
or or whatever
and and here's the thing uh it's a fine
line from
uh hey i align myself with that group
and this is one of my communities who i
love
that's great there's a fine line between
that and
this is my group and if my group is
attacked then i am attacked and if my
group gets a win
then i get a win and if my group is
shamed then i am shamed
because i am the group
right you can see here how my i have no
sense of self outside of the group
i am who we are
uh i heard a story this was about a
tribe
uh that anthropologists studied many
many decades ago
uh and they were fascinated because the
highest punishment
in this tribe was that um someone would
be
banished from the tribes they didn't
really have capital punishment like we
haven't you know in the united states
um but this was kind of their capital
punishment um because you know if you
did a bad thing
you're banished and
what would happen is that although the
banished person
was fully capable of living on their own
like they knew how to live in the wild
and find food and protect themselves at
night
these were highly capable people um
the anthropologist said that inevitably
within just weeks
they would die the banished person would
just die
because their sense of self was so
thoroughly
fused with the group that apart from the
group
they lost all will to live
and this is at a very in a kind of
extreme way this is what happens when i
base my sense of self my
my sense of worth and value um on
the group identity and again am i saying
you know oh
this is terrible we should never join
groups and it's terrible if we drive a
sense of identity and worth from them
no not not exactly i'm kind of what i'm
trying to name is that's normal
all humans grow and develop a sense of
self from the groups we find ourselves
in
um however what i'm trying to name is
that we have to
keep going if we're looking for
solid rock something unmovable to ground
our life and identity in we have to keep
going and keep growing because what
happens
when suddenly i find myself out of step
with my group
what happens when it's time to disagree
or critique them and suddenly the very
group i thought i thought they loved me
the very group i thought was on my side
now it's turned against me and suddenly
my whole sense of self just comes
crashing
down all other ground is
sinking sand third
i build my sense of value on my role
on my role this is a big one for us
americans
um you know the idea here is that i i
build it i build my sense of self on
what i
do i am a teacher someone might say and
so the
the kids see me in a certain way and
society relates to me in a certain way
and i
then come to think of myself in a
certain way i
am that role this is who i am
uh or perhaps for you you know it's i'm
a parent
parenting is what i do it's like for as
long as i can remember this is now what
i've done this is
where i derive my sense of value and
self-worth
from here in this role i am needed
here in this role i am loved here
society
tells me i have value and that makes me
feel oh so good
uh or i am just filling the blank right
whatever whatever you do
i i am a firefighter
i am computer programmer you know
whatever
um you know one that that really gets
people pulled into a very strange
identity
i'll take on my own little tribe for a
while for a moment is
of course the pastor or priest we can
we can be the worst about this because
you know we have these titles
and before you know it our our ego
identity
becomes so aligned with the role
right of or whatever that if we were to
ever
lose the role suddenly
the well now former pastor has a
drinking problem
um right what what happened oh there was
a
loss of identity a loss of sense of self
and of course i mean this isn't just
pastors that struggle with this like
suddenly the kids grow up and leave
and the parents are there kind of
reeling and suddenly dad has a drinking
problem right or the ceo gets fired
and no one wants to hire her and that
pain prescription medication
begins to be abused what what's going on
here we're building our sense of self
um on what jesus calls sinking sand
right
all other ground is sinking
sand fourth and finally i build my sense
of value on my
success my successes
in this one you know i'm someone who has
done things who has accomplished things
big things
or at least big things compared to
others and so i i feel
that i am important until of course
i fail or even get a hint that i am
failing
or struggling and suddenly it's not
simply that i have a challenge facing me
no suddenly i have a full-blown identity
crisis what's happening because we're
living in fear of failure because our
sense of self is
dependent on being a success
uh this is what i talk about on occasion
this is really relevant in my life so
here's an example um this is like a
silly moment but i do i get small tastes
of this
all the time all the time it's just very
tempting for me
and i remember just last sunday um we
all log
on at like 5 p.m you know for our
service and i'm normally sort of like
backstage so to speak on the
we use an app called stream yard uh and
so i'm kind of back there it's like the
beginning
um or i'm there during the service but
at the beginning and end of the service
i'll kind of log into like facebook and
you know check in
comment uh things like that and you know
of course like we're a small community
here so
um and well and also i get many are sick
to death of online services
so we'll normally store but i think
tonight there was like you know nine or
ten people on at you know five o'clock
and uh and then we kind of go you know
up a few maybe from there uh
from the service as it goes on so last
sunday um i get it i mean it was spring
break it was various things
i opened up facebook and i glanced at
the number of people logged on
do you know how many people were logged
on no you don't because
none of you were here well okay now i'm
not a faithful few
adam thompson was here adam thompson is
so
faithful with this online service pretty
amazing um so facebook said three
three people and no joke the thought
just flashed through my mind just for a
second i was like
i've been doing this a year and this is
what it's come to
three people
now okay i was of course being a little
bit you know dramatic
uh moment lost in my ego and within like
30 seconds i just laughed at myself like
okay
you're being silly um but you know
here's the thing right
just a little heart heart examination
sometimes it's those
those little heart pains those little
those little moments of of
ego that that kind of show at least me
you know in that moment what i'm
building my sense of self on right can
you relate to this
like what what are those heart pangs for
you those
moments around success or failure that
suddenly
uh you realize oh gosh i think my
identity was getting
wrapped up in that that idea of success
more than i realized it was what's going
on there well it's them
right all other ground is
sinking sand
and you know again just to reiterate am
i saying all the above things are
terrible like no
oh it's important that as human beings
we have groups that love us
that we find meaningful roles meaningful
work even that we have some wins you
know
gain a little self-confidence that's
that's like such an important step on
the journey
but here's the key for most people
that's
where it ends that's the goal
but for a follower of christ that is
precisely
the beginning now you're ready
for death and resurrection to become a
reality in your life
because at some point if you've built
your sense of self on the previous four
foundations
at some point it starts to crack always
my identity built on sand starts to
look shaky when my spouse says
it's over i can't do this anymore
when i drop my last child off at college
when my boss says i'm so sorry i'm gonna
have to let
you go your family rejects you
when you realize that your friend group
is actually quite dysfunctional and
immature
but now you're lonely when your business
goes
under when your beauty fades and the
wrinkles
start to uh pop up everywhere when the
deck
when the debt collector comes calling
when the dream
whatever it was becomes a nightmare
that's when you know dang it i've been
building on sinking
sand but here's what's so crazy all
along
we fool ourselves so well don't we
and we we cloak ourselves in what we do
in in so much at times religious
language
uh that the whole time we we could have
sworn we were building on the rock
i mean you might say i was going to
church and i even prayed lord
this thing this situation this is yours
this job this
role you know this family this is just
yours god
and i just submit this to you right we
did i did all the right things
but what happened well
don't feel bad happens to all of us our
sense of worth our sense of value our
sense of identity
it got wrapped up in that thing it
wasn't just
a thing we did out of obedience and love
for god and they were not simply people
to be loved because they're great and i
love to love and be loved in return no
it became more than that i started to
base my sense of value
on those things and so while i thought
it was
on christ the solid rock i stand in
actuality
it was sinking sand
which is why i started this message by
asking
what do you need to die to so that you
can really live because as
long as your identity is fused with your
family and what they think of you
or your group and what they think of you
or your roles or your successes and i
mean i could just keep going your
possessions your power your 401k your
good standing in the community
as long as that is ultimate you will
forever be building on sinking
sand you will forever be building on a
shaky foundation
why because you cannot control
what others think of you and you cannot
control at least not completely what
happens
in your life i mean you can do your best
to you know treat others well
and try hard but ultimately how that is
received and the exact
return you get on that investment so to
speak that's
like beyond you
one of the main things um just to bring
this a little closer to home
for me one of the main things i have
been uh
really having to die to in the last two
years or so uh is the idea that
everyone thinks well of me
and and really it's the idea that that i
can think well of me
because others think well of me uh most
of you
know that we are a a pretty new church
all things considered we launched in
um november of 2019 and we launched as a
gay affirming church in the suburbs
of north dallas and uh you know i mean
we're in texas and so let's just say
that a lot of people
don't agree they don't agree
uh with us they don't agree with me
right from maybe from family to former
tribes i was a part of to friends
to fellow area pastors there's you know
there's a lot of head shaking
and at best it's sort of
you know we love you but how could you
be so stupid
and at worst it's since when did you
join team
satan and i i laugh
but i laugh so i don't cry because deep
down here's the truth
i wanna be loved i want people to
celebrate me
i want them to say hooray i believe in
what you and what you're doing
i want them to be on team brett and team
table
even if from afar but you know what
um some are which is awesome
but you know a lot art most aren't
and you know what else that's okay
that's okay because there was a part of
my heart
that had built my sense of self on what
they
thought of me and that part of me
is having to die
it's having to die and is it easy
no no it's a painful process
but is it good yes
yes this is a lengthy quote i came
across
from christian writer uh richard rohr
but i think it's worth
every word he says this
most of us have learned to say no
without the deeper joy of yes
we were trained to put up with all of
the
dying he puts that in quotes he doesn't
mean it literally he's talking about in
kind of a christian spiritual context
like i've been talking about
we were trying to put up with all the
dying and just take it on the chin
saying no to the false self does not
necessarily please god or please anybody
and surely not you
there is too much resentment and self
pity
involved in this kind of false dying
there is a good dying and there is a bad
die
good dying is unto something bigger
and better bad dying is just
damn stupid dying that profits nobody
it is too much no and not enough
yes you must hold out
for yes don't be against anything unless
you are much
more for it first or for something else
that is better god tries to first create
a joyous
yes inside you far more than any kind of
no
and then you have become god's full
work of art and for you
love is now stronger than death and
christ
is surely risen in you
and this is why jesus said truly i tell
you unless a kernel of wheat falls to
the ground
and dies it remains only a single
seed but if it dies it produces
many seeds you see if your take away
from this message is a gloomy
eeyore-ish well it's the season of lent
time to take up my cross gotta die
to some stuff uh you are
misunderstanding
and if your takeaway from my story is oh
brett wow that sounds like it's been
terrible
i hate this for you uh you are missing
it
because no it's been wonderful i mean
momentarily terrible at points for sure
but in the long run
it's been completely wonderful i am more
free than ever you see what's terrible
is living your whole life with this
fragile sense of self-dependence on what
others think about you
what's terrible is is basically
wondering
if your identity and in the world will
come crashing down if your string of
successes
runs out what's terrible is being
emotionally
fused to the number in your bank account
or your position
or role in life no no that's not
strength
and and that's not joy that that's
that's
weakness and that's ego it's
sinking sand
but now what is happening what is jesus
inviting us into
we are being invited into a
fruitful a productive a a
good life remember he said until you die
you cannot produce
many seeds when we live from a place
rooted in god's love and what god says
about us
then we are fruitful and you say well
what do you mean
like fruitful i mean then we can change
lives for the better then people can be
impacted
by our love you can't love people that
you are desperately
emotionally fused with
that's a word for someone like you're
you're using
them you need them too many pastors
using their congregations
for an ego boost too many parents
building the foundation of their life on
top of their children
and squashing them in the process too
many
friends using their friends
desperate for their next hit of love and
acceptance
no no no that's not loving
and so this is why the invitation from
jesus is so beautiful because he's
saying
die to that die to that
let go trust me learn
to rely on my love that
is all you need
now in closing you might ask how on
earth do i learn
to do this and the truth is it ties in
really closely with my message
last week because here's the thing your
whole life is conspiring to get you to
do this
wherever you have suffering wherever you
are
hacked off at life or other people
wherever
you experience very strong challenging
emotions of anger
bitterness fear it's a sign my friends
it's the sign
that that's precisely the sign that you
have something
to die to it's a sign of a place
where you have been building your
identity
your sense of self-worth and value on
sand so stop blaming others
it's not them it's you you've got some
business
with god to do because as richard orr
said
it's a sign that god has a bigger
yes he has a huge joy-filled
fearless yes to life
that he is inviting you into
so friends step into it
step into it so as we go into our final
song
you know the question i want you to sit
with maybe you jot it down in your phone
or your journal
what do you need to die to so that you
can really live let me pray for you
or jesus would you
um give us the courage to
face into our fears to face into
our the sinking sand areas of our
lives
so that we can die to it and then really
live and be be a rooted grounded
foundation people
in you and who you say we are so we love
you in the powerful name of jesus i pray
amen
thank you brett um
you guys might remember us doing this
song last week it's called letting go
i just wanted to go back to it tonight
and take some time to respond to these
lyrics
i'm just gonna play for a minute at
first and give us a second
to take inventory of our thoughts and
our emotions
[Music]
and um
yeah just respond to god's spirit
if there's anything going on there
[Music]
just when my hallelujah
falling into
i confess i still get scared sometimes
the perfect love comes rushing
in
[Music]
the moment
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
tears
until i'm totally undone
with your arms
[Music]
with your me
i'm
[Music]
falling into
falling again
thanks mindy and thanks brett for that
really
really good and needed message i'm so
glad you were here with us tonight
i hope that the service and the music
blessed you
and reminded you that you're not alone
um
if you are new to the table and just
getting to know us
a great place to find out more and to
connect more with us
is at our website and you can find that
at
thetabletx.org that's the table
tx.org you can
check out our vision our values
it also has a place where you can give
if you'd like to
a place to get connected with our
meetups
to get the address for pleasant valley
which is where we're going to start
meeting in person
mid-april so thetabletx.org is a great
place
to go and find out more about our
community
um and before we
close out tonight i want to share this
benediction with you as we go into
our week and if you've joined us before
if i've been in the service
this is a benediction that i give every
time
that i am doing the service closeout
because i don't
think that we can hear it too much i
know i
i can't hear it too much i need to be
reminded of this
uh daily and as brett was talking in his
message and sharing
i was thinking that you know some of us
need
to die to things that that people have
said about us
um labels that have been put on us um
old tapes that play in our minds that
are
negative and derogatory um
our own inner critics uh self-loathing
self-hatred um or just the common garden
variety
like you know we're just insecure um
and so this benediction is really meant
to be
um that bedrock not
this is not a sinking sand benediction
this is bedrock this is something
that you can bet on you can bet your
life on this because it is
true and so if you're listening to this
right now this benediction
is for you and it includes you so i hope
you receive it
like that you are a child of god
this is true on your best days and on
your worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only
one you nothing about you is a mistake
and this world needs you being fully
yourself
authentic and free so as you go into the
week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in between go with the
assurance
that you are loved you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you
come in contact with
i hope you have a good and fruitful week
and i hope to see you back here next
sunday
bye
you